well something important to notice is
nevada
is one of the states that is not enough
mental health providers
for the amount of people you need so it
always has been in a high demand
for recipients to receive appropriate
mental health services but now due to
kobe
the anyone's anxiety depression so we
have seen
an increase of need for mental health
services
children are experiencing a very extreme
the social isolation is affecting them
their morale
their spirit they're not interacting
with other children playing
and they are feeling depressed
and bored their levels of anxiety are
higher they sometimes they are afraid to
as the teachers
some of the things that are not
understanding at school and then
it's difficult for them to do some
testing so their grades are becoming
lower
and they're not really feeling engaged
with some of the school activities for
most of people holidays is a very
important moment because it brings up
family together as well as different
traditions and activities
some people in the holiday time they eat
actually they get more depressed and
it's called the holiday blues
uh where maybe they have some past
history of trauma or maybe some having
some
family problems that actually uh the
holidays
brings up some of sadness and and it's
not so
fun for some people during this pandemic
situation
we're very concerned that some people
that we're getting already the holiday
blues
in this year even might be a little bit
more difficult for them
so it's important that anybody seeing
this if
you can ask for help it's okay to ask
for help there's a
something called cabin syndrome that we
feel that we're trapped with the same
people and then we feel annoyed or we
feel
stressed and then if if it was already
some tension before
when you are for so many hours together
with that same person
that tension increases and unfortunately
in this year of 2020 we have seen an
increase of domestic violence
suicidal attempts more substance abuse
problems
more family dynamic problems so it's
very important to reach out for help
civil state is a federal qualified
health center that provides
many services as mental health medical
psychiatric and case management the
number is 702-471-0420
mental health or individual therapy
family sessions are being through
telemedicine primary care and
psychiatric services are being in person
we focus on the solutions not on the
problems and
if a person needs someone else to help
them and provide more support
we will find a way of reach that help to
that person
las vegas we suffer a traumatic event on
october 1st 2017
and a lot of survivors and family
affected by
route 91 tragic event it's important to
reach out for help silver state health
services is providing
free services for anyone that is a
survivor
or a secondary victim from this event so
anybody that
is a a victim a direct victim or a
direct person impacted by
october 1st tragedy as well as direct
family members
can reach out for help for help first
for free we have seen increase of
domestic violence
divorces
child custody problems
traumatic events
definitely an increase in child abuse
financial stress
and that financial stress is also
causing some
we've seen higher levels of depression
suicidal ideation and higher levels of
anxiety
also there's a study from the state
of nevada the suicidal prevention
there has been an increase on suicidal
attempts by
female teenager hispanic girls
one of the main issues is the lack of
communication between parents and
children
especially in the hispanic community
parents don't speak spanish
the parents don't speak english and the
children are not speaking spanish so
there's no communication
there's a cultural barrier as well as
the language barrier
also there's a lack of understanding
between generations as well as
immigration
issues that is causing a lot of stress
in the family that the children are
scared
and afraid that their parents may be
deported
or themselves if there are dreamers
and lastly maybe